[Applaus]
sie sind krank und wollen nichts als
leben
sie warten auf ein organ dass ein
verstorbener spendet
ein leben geht zu ende
eines wird verlängert die
organtransplantation ist ein eingriff
der bewegt es geht um ethik glaube
gesetz und moral
um großes glück
ich freue mich darauf wie verrückt jetzt
auf diesen nächsten abschnitt in meinem
leben und bin sehr dankbar dass ich das
alles erleben darf und um ängste was
bedeutet die transplantation für die
empfängerinnen und empfänger wie genau
läuft sie ab
[Musik]
doch wahnsinnig geduld
wie es die lebensqualität nach dem
großen eingriff es geht um warten
hoffnung und vielleicht erlösung
[Musik]
schweizerisches kinder lieber zentrum in
genf
das ist deine haut zeigen
nach der leber-transplantation liegt mir
noch immer in der narkose vor fast zwölf
stunden kann sie angst im operationssaal
kurz vor der transplantation maria rast
leidet an einem seltenen gendefekt
zweimal schon versagte ihre leber sie
überlebte wie durch ein wunder
zwar hat sie sich erholt ein einfacher
infekt aber können wieder
lebensbedrohlich werden die ärzte sehen
nur eine lösung für die heilung eine
lebertransplantation
[Musik]
nach kurzer wartezeit wird maria in genf
operiert
mich freut die eltern bangen im
warteraum die kinder chirurgin barbara
wildhaber kann sie etwas beruhigen
[Musik]
rund zehn stunden dauerte die
transplantation sie ist soweit gut
verlaufen
der nächste morgen
maria ist noch nicht ganz zu sich
gekommen
die oft nur ganze mit kammern und die
ganze linie
doch noch den sieg
euro
alles dort auch musik machen
[Musik]
die kleine patientin wird sich rasch
erholen in diesen ersten tagen nicola
heiser verlässt das inselspital in bern
sie lebt seit neun jahren mit einem
spenderherz regelmäßig geht sie zur
untersuchung an den tagen wo ich weiß
ich hierher nur zur kontrolle und es ist
alles gut und und dann sind natürlich
auch die tage wo es mir nicht so gut
geht sind dann nicht so angenehm wieder
herzugeben dann kommt alles wieder doch
mehr hoch auch die negativen erlebnisse
nach der transplantation traten
komplikationen auf unter anderem ein
nierenversagen
der weg war so holprig dass sie kurz
zweifelte ob die operation der richtige
schritt war aber nur eine
transplantation konnte ihr leben retten
[Musik]
vor dem eingriff war nicola häuser
unendlich müde herzinsuffizienz so die
diagnose
den vierzigsten geburtstag verbringt sie
mit ihrer familie die aus deutschland
angereist ist sie wartet auf die
transplantation hat doch schon ein
bisschen angst vor und wer weiß wann man
wieder so fröhlich zusammen ist also das
weiß man ja wirklich nicht tochter ana
paula übergibt ihr geschenkt heute leben
die beiden in niederwangen bei bern wie
alle transplantierten menschen muss
nicola häuser immunsuppressiva zu sich
nehmen
die verhindern dass der körper das
fremde organ abstößt
diese medikamente haben nebenwirkungen
aber herbst antibiotikum eben gerade
abgesetzt mal gesagt ich kann das schon
richtig gesagt wieso ist das so dunkel
geworden ist kann ich sein alles gut
wenn man diese für über mit dem
lockenstab hat für die konformation wie
fertig gemacht abgerutscht nur einmal
kurz gegen dann habe ich nicht gleich
gefühlt weil wir keine zeit hatten und
dann war es natürlich gleich entzündet
und dann tat es immer mehr weh und am
abend musste ich im notfall gehen weil
das war schon bisher unten alles so rund
rot runter gelaufen
das ist halt wenn man immunsupprimierten
ist passiert so was mal schneller weil
das immunsystem ist runter gesetzt und
der körper hilft sich nicht sonst würde
er das herz wieder abstoßen
diese medikamente erhöhen auch das
krebsrisiko bei nikolaisaal musste
dreimal weißer hautkrebs entfernt werden
dazu kam eine unterleibsoperation wegen
auffälliger veränderungen aber ohne die
medikamente geht es nicht so kleine sind
beide institutionen noch und was für die
gefäße so prophylaktisch dass das nicht
ablagerungen gibt glaube ich
und jetzt hab ich gerade fieber blasen
dann muss ich extra was ein virus endes
nehmen weil sonst entzündet sich das
alles und ich kriege so digel im knoten
also man sieht ja kaum ich habe sie
gerade am anfang genommen
aber wenn ich da nicht gleich
rechtzeitig was nehmen oder ein zwei
tage wartet dann ist es alles
geschwollen hier und tut wahnsinnig weh
ja und dann einfach magnesium und kalium
noch und kalzium
ja das ist so mein dass der abend lose
so gleich nach der transplantation
musste nicola häuser über 30 medikamente
nehmen
dabei hatte sie schon vor dem großen
eingriff genug davon
[Musik]
wegen der transplantation hat nicola
heißer momente wie die einschulung der
tochter verpasst ana paula musste lernen
mit der krankheit der mutter zu leben
ich habe schon eingeholt und ich habe
dann einfach so gedacht ja das war schon
echt viel glück dass jetzt noch bei mir
sein kann das mache ich auch oft
beschäftigt mich das eigentlich noch
ja aber ich genieße jeden moment mit ihr
dass sie noch da es macht mich sehr
glücklich
[Musik]
du musst du so an die leine
inselspital bern
auf der intensivstation liegt eine
patientin die nach einer gehirnblutung
verstorben ist
der hirntod wurde offiziell festgestellt
weil die frau organspenderin ist wird
sie beatmet und gewärmt um die organe zu
erhalten
lucy christen ist organspende
koordinatorin am inselspital
sie steht in ständigem kontakt mit den
angehörigen dass sie oft eine
patientenverfügung mach es ist wie so
häufig im lackierte richtig zielpunkt
sie und offenbare sich positiv zur
organspende und jacke gottfroh dass es
jedem finish racer entschieden
der zustand der organe ist medizinisch
überprüft worden
die empfänger sind bestimmt jetzt geht
es in den operationssaal zur
organentnahme die angehörigen haben den
dreharbeiten zugestimmt
aus rücksicht auf sie wurden für diesen
film mehrere organentnahmen gedreht und
die bilder zusammengefügt das dient der
anonymisierung
die meisten organ spenderinnen und
spender haben einen hirnschlag oder eine
hirnblutungen erlitten
die organspende nach einem hirntod als
primäre todesursache ist häufiger als
die organspende nach dem herztod
[Musik]
die transplantation chirurgin vanessa
bands wird die organentnahme übernehmen
nach einem vollen arbeitstag mit
koordinatorin lucy christen prüft sie
die unterlagen vanessa bands kennt beide
seiten implantieren und ex plant ihren
[Musik]
vorsichtig sagt für das wäre und ich
auch dass man keine verletzung macht
dann plötzlich dazu führen so gar nicht
auf
eigentlich ist es eine operation wie
andere auch aber für einmal nicht
zugunsten des operierten sondern der
organempfänger zwei leben berühren sich
die kosten der entnahme trägt die
krankenkasse des organ empfängers
insgesamt kommt eine transplantation auf
100.000 bis 250.000 franken zu stehen
der markus der schlüssel pro bahn
der bvb hat es mit 55 gestarteten 20 18
schnitt kamen
und ich würde mal größere klappe bewusst
sind für ganz die top lucy christen
überwacht und protokolliert lebendig
später das telefon zum zentrum
dokumentieren wenn ich spüre ich kann
auch wenn es so gar nicht gebe
ich habe dich immer bewundert
ich weiß ich werde jetzt schwierig zum
fest aber es ist eine wunderschöne
operation ganz oft wieder mensch gemacht
ist das was per se wahnsinnig
faszinierend wie das alles funktioniert
wieder so viele abgestimmt ist wie wie
sinnvoll irgendwie alles ist es jetzt
alles weg und ich genau die etwas hat
sie und und das hilft so zum das ganze
land aber so viel blut muss man sagen es
ist eine wunderschöne operation und
aussieht wie der junge leute die bringen
und zeigen will meine füllte
[Musik]
universitätsspital genf eine woche ist
zeit mir erst transplantation vergangen
seit der letzten acht ist sie auf der
intensivstation
es sind komplikationen aufgetreten die
eltern sind am ende die ständige angst
zerrt an den nerven was uns
es ist komisch die läster portals sehr
gute fortschritte gemacht und jetzt ist
wieder ein rückschritt scheint er ist
das eine gute natürliche ist eine
umfahrung vergangen und eigene also
jetzt schlecht und der fliegt
die neue transplantierte leber es
handelt sich um den teil einer
erwachsenen leber blutet die chirurgin
barbara wildhaber versucht jetzt die
flüssigkeit in einem schlauch abzuleiten
marias bauch ist stark geprägt sie
möchte sofort operiert werden
naja der hauptstadt schien ops wird gut
für dich entscheiden ob es könne nichts
wie weg das war damit so durch diese
gäste kommen damit wir schnell von
großen ich habe immer vorwärts machen
sie ist so vernünftig unglaublich sie
will in den operationssaal dort
transfusionen braucht und sich neue ganz
still und in eine situation muss man
leider hatte das boot geholt und musik
hat eine operation machen sich nicht
ganz einfach für familie sich eine ganz
einfach für leuchten wenn er ja die
allerletzte aber sicher und richtig ist
[Musik]
na
nach zweieinhalb stunden ist es
überstanden
[Musik]
der eingriff ist gut verlaufen
das buch eigentlich wirklich mit zeit
dann ist flüssigkeit k&k politik quelle
kunden also wahrscheinlich aber wenn wir
dort im schnitt vielleicht hätte
obermeister klagt sie
und wenn ich selber so dass die
befragung auch der bilder sind jährlich
hat mir ein tor gelingt wenn es
durchgehend zufolge wichtig ist der
hüttenindustrie also sowieso das haben
wir nur zu den untersuchungen habe es
aber nicht
katja rast reicht auch auf der
intensivstation nicht von ihrer seite
[Musik]
die ehemalige spitzensportlerin nicola
häuser kommt zur arbeit
sie trainiert rivaldo das turnier pferd
eines kunden und gibt einigen kunden
reitunterricht tochter ana paula reitet
erfolgreich bei nachwuchsturnieren mit
[Musik]
vor der herztransplantation war nicola
heißer so geschwächt dass sie nicht mehr
retten konnte das ist schon sehr großer
frust für mich ist für mich sicher nicht
die priorität dass ich wieder aufs feld
kommen aber ich sag jetzt mal wenn ich
wenn das im glücklichsten fall dann noch
wieder möglich ist dass ich wieder ein
pferd reiten kann welche natürlich
überglücklich das war der absolute also
der osternacht weihnacht zu sagen dass
irgendwie schön also aber das ist sicher
nicht das wichtigste
das wichtigste ist eigentlich dass ich
mal wieder normales leben führen kann
nicola heiser feierte als
dressurreiterin große erfolge
sie stammt aus einer dynastie von
reitern und pferdezüchter
[Applaus]
macht mich schon traurig wenn man hat
eine verzierung und das ist irgendwie so
herz von hart es dauerte lange bis
nicola häuser wieder zu kräften kam dann
aber wollte sie trotz des gedrosselten
immunsystems zurück zu den pferden gegen
den rat der ärzte haben mir eigentlich
damals gesagt dass ich so entstellt ich
ja nicht mehr darf und dann haben wir
mal für mich gesagt so ja aber ich bin
mit dem dreck groß geworden ich bin seit
klein auf ein kleines kleinem kind im
stall und jeden tag und ich würde so
gerne probieren und sie haben einfach
gesagt die gefahr von diesen pilzen und
spuren die hier umfliegen dass es auf
die lunge geht es sehr groß und und dann
nachher bei der jungen problem macht und
und von daher war das denn nachher also
haben sie das ist auf jeden fall
probieren aber vorsichtig und habe nie
ein problem gehabt
das ist mir auch bewusst dass es
eigentlich eigentlich geschenk ist jeden
tag dass ich hingehen kann es schon
fertig ja die pferde verlangen ihr alles
ab ich merkte vermeiden
also ich bin dann schon ziemlich
erledigt und ich könnte jetzt glaube ich
meinen beruf glaubt nicht mehr 100
prozent mit dem reiten meinen tag
ausfüllen
[Musik]
ana paula bist du fertig fertig ist
schade
am inselspital hat vanessa bands
inzwischen die organentnahme vorbereitet
sally matthews die leber ist sehr schön
leben ist sehr schön
wir würden sie nein überhaupt nicht
ganz scharfe kommt und ganz glatte
oberfläche wie würden sie selber gerade
behaupten
okay wenn man möchtest du noch ein
telefon
da das gas kommt denke ich ja der
patient wird noch immer beatmet der
kreislauf gestützt er ist narkotisiert
trotz hirntod reflexe vorhaben gesehen
damit nehmen die kreislauf nach wie vor
will er wird der patient hirntot ist wie
man den kreislauf voll unterstützen dass
er gebraucht seiner nach großer wo es da
hilft es sind reflexe des rückenmarks
die unterdrückt werden müssen
für die entnahme der lunge ist mitten in
der nacht sven hähner angereist
leitender arzt am zürcher unispital die
spezialisten der empfänger zentren
exportieren die organe für ihre
patienten meistens selber vanessa bands
nutzt die gelegenheit für eine kurze
pause ein café gegen die müdigkeit ich
das nicht planbar und mehr mit ihnen
steckt quasi die ganze woche für apple
tv hat bis 100 umständen fehler oder gar
nicht mit den schon sieben das ist
gleich wichtig muss ich haben ermittelt
dass die der nacht und einen tag
in dieser phase assistiert vanessa bands
ihren kollegen
es steht der entscheidende moment bevor
der blutkreislauf wird unterbrochen
die hauptschlagader abgeklemmt
klar heißt das in der fachsprache der
körper wird mit als gefüllt die
maschinen werden abgestellt nur die
lunge wird noch kurz mit sauerstoff
versorgt
eine spülflüssigkeit ersetzt das blut
die narkose erübrigt sich jetzt in
seltenen fällen wird das auch den profis
zu viel wenn hillinger begutachtet die
lunge er ist zufrieden
[Musik]
die lunge kann sechs bis maximal acht
stunden außerhalb des körpers bleiben
[Musik]
rasch machen sich die ärzte des
universitätsspitals zürich auf den
rückweg
für die entnahme der verbleibenden
organe übernimmt wieder vanessa bands
dem lied das kinderspital in genf eine
woche ist vergangen seit mehr als
neuerliche operation
sie ist hungrig obwohl die nacht unruhig
verlief mirja hatte angst vor den
medikamenten des nächsten tages
[Musik]
nach banane stoff stellt und hätten
weiterhin drin hat wieso bist du ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt der extrem schnell
auf dem programm steht physiotherapie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nicola heiser und ana paula werden bald
abschied nehmen
sie verlassen die schweiz und ziehen um
in die nähe von hamburg
nicolas heimat also kannst du einmal
geschehen schreibt diverses oder teller
besteck und geschirr ein großer schritt
nach 22 jahren in der schweiz
das hat sich so ergeben auch für den tod
von vater und meine schwester macht
jetzt den hof alleine und erst recht
groß und dann ist mir eben auch noch
bewusst geworden dass ich doch die zeit
mit meiner familie genießen muss und
oder möchte muss und sie mir auch sehr
viel ich habe immer viel heimweh gehabt
als dann eben meine schwester fragte ob
ich nicht nach hause kommen will
hab ich gehört ja ein bisschen
bald sind es zehn jahre seit dem
nikolaisaal mit dem spenderherz lebt
muss man schon recht beißen nicht immer
nur das ist mir alles leicht fällt und
ja aber im großen und ganzen bin ich
eigentlich sehr zufrieden ich bin
einfach ich hab gar nicht aber hat das
überhaupt so guten jemals wieder wird
aber natürlich immer wenn man ein
bisschen ein zirka hingekriegt hat er
was gefühlt könnte doch noch mehr gehen
und vielleicht noch ein leckeres
schokoladenmousse kommen das kommt nicht
mehr
[Musik]
ganz unbeschwert ist der alltag nicht
wir sind schon ängste da kann es nicht
anders sagen ja man kann tage und wochen
wegstecken und dann fragt man sich
natürlich auch wie lange geht das noch
alles so und man spricht nicht so drüber
weil ja warum soll man angst haben jetzt
gut geht
aber ich weiß ja auch dass der körper
unter den medikamenten die ich jeden tag
nehmen muss auch recht leitet
[Musik]
statistisch betrachtet leben nach zehn
jahren noch mehr als 65 prozent der herz
transplantierten gemäss den zahlen des
unispitals zürich sind es nach 20 jahren
noch rund 50 prozent
am operationstisch steht vanessa bands
kurz vor der entnahme von liebe und
nieren
die lieber durch bitte eine riesige
schar ibiza sie wird so fortgespült
damit verbleiben das blut nicht gerinnt
die organe werden standardmäßig verpackt
es werden keine spende und das getrübt
wurde mit 50 jahre hand wo neben so
optimal ist und er geht mit sagt auch
die wunderschöne lage haben so gut zu
den fluten
das nicht
[Musik]
der versand der unbezahlbaren fracht
liegt in der verantwortung von
koordinatorin luci christen
und der spezialisierten
transportunternehmens a
[Musik]
der körper des organspenders ist wieder
zugenäht worden
[Musik]
die station kontakt mit im
aufbahrungsraum werden sich auch die
angehörigen verabschieden können
[Musik]
in genf wartet familie rast auf den
bescheid der ärzte ein monat ist seit
der transplantation vergangen
alle drei möchten nach hause
jetzt zieht wo sie auch getrennt bis
jetzt plötzlich seien nun sind mit
mandeln papier eines tages verweigerte
mirja die medikamente sie mussten ihr
zweimal mit einer ernährungssonde
verabreicht werden
auch heute gibt es einen rückschlag das
bauch ist wieder geschwollen nachricht
[Musik]
wollte wir machen die die funktion für
die flüssigkeit sowas woche eine reglose
ist der opa deinen bauch geschossen
[Musik]
die eltern wissen die bevorstehende
entnahme der gewebeflüssigkeit ist
entscheidend bei schlechtem bescheid
wenn fett in der flüssigkeit ist
arbeitet die leber noch nicht richtig
lachgas soll mir er durch den eingriff
helfen
[Musik]
es ist wichtig
jetzt heißt es warten auf die
laborergebnisse auch für die ärzte in
dem der flüssigkeit
[Musik]
aber nur
maria darf das wochenende in der wohnung
verbringen die das spital den eltern zur
verfügung stellt eine erlösung
marc meier
[Musik]
jetzt ist katja in der verantwortung die
medikamente zu richten
freud
[Musik]
mehr
und so geht es weiter
[Musik]
eliane gutzwiller ist lungen
transplantiert und leidet unter einer
chronischen abstoßung des organs auf
social media berichtet sie offen über
ihr leben
christian reutemann wartet auf eine
spenderlunge ein paar minuten auf dem
fitness welle
mehr geht nicht mehr und mehr er rast
und ihre familie sind endlich wieder zu
hause
in der nächsten folge
gleich nach einer kurzen pause
[Musik]